on this Mother's Day there's lots of
virtual hugging going on everyone is
longing for the day when we can get
close again for those women who are
pregnant right now motherhood is about
to get very real babies of course don't
wait around for a crisis to subside what
is it like to be expecting in the midst
of all of this
well we're following a couple who are
due to have their first baby in just a
few days they've been documenting their
journey of what to expect when you are
expecting during a pandemic I'm Kareem
and I'm Eli and we're having a baby and
the time of coronavirus it's true we met
four years ago while I was at Vancouver
for work I was living in Toronto she was
living in Vancouver so he did the
long-distance thing for a while bouncing
back and forth between the two cities a
big part of our lives and a relationship
is travelling and adventures whether
it's camping interesti exploring new
countries or just going for a hike we
love getting outside and trying new
things
so when we found out last fall we were
pregnant we were pretty pumped to embark
on this new adventure we were in Ontario
at the time and things started off
fairly normal doctor's visits this is
what you look like in 19 weeks
hanging out with friends and family we
headed back west in January we even went
on a babymoon to Palm Springs toured
around on bikes elephant cruiser bikes
not so easy green killing it up there
she's biking for to exploit Joshua Tree
clownish in the pools life was good but
after we got back things started to
change pretty quickly the reality is
that the number of people affected by
the virus around the globe keeps
climbing coronavirus was becoming more
of a thing and people were starting to
talk about it it started with little
things like no more high-fives of
volleyball then an environmental
conference I was to attend in Vegas got
canceled and the next thing you know
things started shutting down I was
really excited for my sister to come
visit in March but we had to cancel her
trip questions started being raised
about our health care options as we
entered the third trimester and our
day-to-day shifted as everyone started
isolating can we go to the hospital is
the hospital even safe if we get sick
the baby get Kovac and my mom still what
does this mean financially how long is
this going to lie or do we go from here
there are a lot of questions and to most
the answer was unknown it doesn't stress
you out that I can't come to the
appointments in person no the first time
definitely was a little bit more intense
because it was our first appointment
during coal bed so the midwives were
wearing masks there's no one else in the
waiting room it just had a totally
different feel but now that we've done
it a few times and you can still
participate in call in and ask questions
and hear our updates it's okay so like
everyone we had to trust in the experts
stay at home and focus on what we can
control
like makeshift grocery masks I don't
have a real mask so I'm using my ski
mask to cover my face just as an attempt
to make it a little bit safer I got my
hand sanitizer I got my lifestyle wipes
the reality is we're 39 weeks in and if
I get kovin now I won't be able to be
there for the birth of my child which
would suck so ski masks up let's get
some pampers
and watching everything that came in the
house just in case could be nice
analyzed enough we wrote our birth wish
list it'd be nice to be in a hospital
birth to be able to come back input yeah
in order to pull it we installed the car
seat dad life we tried to stay active
with workouts and going to the beach our
social life moved online we took her own
maternity folders I started wrapping up
work and we join an online group with
other expecting parents we took a baby
class online and I joined our Midwife
appointments from my phone through it
all we were blessed with love and
support from friends and family they
kept us grounded and helped us celebrate
this new chapter a friend made us a
quilt my cousin's staff made us a mobile
and loved one spoiled us with
hand-me-downs and thoughtful gifts they
even planned a surprise shower over zoo
I heard someone say the other day we're
all on the same storm but we're in
different boats but I think that is so
true we've been blessed with a healthy
pregnancy and because we are in DC at
the moment our birth options are pretty
stable we could still have our midwives
and our doula and I can still attend the
birth but for many that's not the case
everybody's situation is different and
everyone handles things differently this
isn't really what I pictured for the
our pregnancy there have been
disappointments and tears but at the end
of the day we are okay and we have so
much to be grateful for we don't know
what the future holds
especially during this pandemic things
could go totally sideways at a moment's
notice but for now we're just gonna try
and make the most of things soak it all
in because this baby will be here before
we know it
[Music]